[Music]
all right we're bringing you now some
breaking news coming in from the u.s
where the supreme court has overturned
the law that allowed states to ban
abortions that law was called roe versus
wade the court made the ruling in a six
to three
ruling by its conservative majority it
upholds the republican-backed
mississippi law that bans abortions
after 15 weeks we're looking at some
live pictures coming in as you can see
i think we've got crowds representing
both sides of the argument
definitely we've got some people who are
pro abortion there as well
and some signs of people who are clearly
against it this was a very
pivotal landmark ruling in 1973 when the
u.s supreme court said basically
it recognized the woman's constitutional
right to decide on an abortion
and legalized it nationwide
now most abortions have been legal in
the united states for nearly 50 years
since that ruling as i said it was a
quite a pivotal landmark decision
brought many unexpected changes
pathy carlheim
has more for us
[Music]
abortion wasn't always controversial in
the united states it was legal when the
country was founded up until what they
called the quickening when the mother
could feel the baby around four months
but by the 1880s abortion was outlawed
across most of the country it stayed
that way until the 60s as the woman's
movement came into force pressure
mounted on the court first it struck
down a law of the band selling birth
control to married couples then later
for unmarried adults family planning
information service would you hold on
wade in 1973 changed the lives of
millions of women allowing all abortions
in the first trimester and some
restrictions in the second a decision
reaffirmed several times since by the
supreme court
before the decision on roe wealthy women
could travel out of the country for the
procedure but for lower income women
getting an abortion often meant going to
unsafe clinics in 1965 17 percent of all
deaths due to pregnancy were the results
of illegal abortions and after roe there
was an economic impact women could
choose to stay in the workforce they
could start for example an advanced
education program
they could get accepted into such a
program because a school would say i
find it credible that this woman will
actually complete her education and not
drop out
because she'll be able to plan uh it
allowed women to invest in careers as
opposed to just jobs
because they could they could follow
paths that involved investment rather
than being viewed by employers as people
who were sort of here today gone
tomorrow
studies have shown that women who leave
their job to care for their child even
for a short time rarely recoup their
earning potential and many can't afford
child care in this country which now
costs an average of fourteen thousand
dollars per year there are some economic
studies that say there is also a link
between legal abortions and a drop in
crime
this reversal will now mean half of the
women in the country are about to find
out what life was like before roe v wade
a half a century ago especially for
women with little means have a child
they don't want or risk their lives to
illegally get an abortion
let's go live now to patikalhein she is
in washington dc this is quite a
dramatic political development right
this is not just a legal issue in the
courts
no this is going to have huge
implications sorry about that i'm just
the decision just came out it's hundreds
of pages i was just trying to see if
this compared to the leaked version
which we never really get from the
supreme court but we knew that this was
a possibility because the original
decision leaked out about a month ago so
i was just scrolling through it doesn't
appear at first glance that anything has
changed it flatly overrules roe v wade
what does that mean it says the court
says now it's up to the states so in
practicality right now 13 states have
outlawed abortion they had trigger laws
on the books that basically said the
minute this decision comes down abortion
is illegal in many of those cases
there's no exemptions not for the health
of the mother not for uh fetal
abnormality 26 states in all are
expected to go ahead so more than a
majority are going to go ahead and
put in laws in place that either ban
abortion or severely restrict abortion
and this is mostly going to happen in
the south the midwest and parts of the
west so what you're going to see now is
a two-tier system places like washington
dc nearby maryland you will be able to
get a safe legal abortion in states like
texas
and
in other southern states you're not
going to have that access at all so what
happens now well there are groups that
are promising to come up with funding so
that people who live in those states if
they need an abortion can travel outside
of their states to get an abortion but
that's not going to be able to help
every woman who needs an abortion and
this will have a disproportionate effect
on women of color and lower income women
because they
overwhelmingly will not be able to
afford to travel out of state they may
not be able to get those private funds
this is an absolutely huge decision now
keep in mind three of the supreme court
justices who made this decision possible
were recently confirmed by the senate
and at least in the case of neil gorsuch
and brett kavanaugh they told senators
that they considered roe v wade to be
settled law basically precedent so how
do they explain that change of opinion
in this decision well they simply say
roe v what roe v wade was much less
plessy versus ferguson which involved
segregation was just simply a bad ruling
and so therefore it just needs to be
overturned so this is a supreme court
that has said precedence matters
basically what the courts before them
have said should be taken into account
they are now saying that that is no
longer the case because they say it's
simply a flawed decision and
all right let's take a moment to just
listen in if we can patty to the
protesters i think that'll give us a
feeling of
of what sentiment how sentiment is
running right now choice than to pay the
abortion industry who will profit off of
her despair you will tell her
you can choose both and we will stand
with you
friends this is not the end of the
pro-life generation now the personal
generation this is the next phase
[Applause]
[Music]
we will call for this moment each and
every one of us we were called for this
moment
and this is a heady responsibility
to make abortion unthinkable and illegal
throughout our nation
to ensure no woman stands alone and
opposed to america to be
the post row generation
as we can clearly see their feelings
running very high over this issue as it
has for years if not decades in the us
where public opinion quite divided on
the issue of abortion for those just
joining us we've got quite a dramatic
u-turn going on by the supreme court
which has overturned something called
the roe versus wade law that was a 1973
law by the supreme court that found it
within a woman's constitutional rights
to have an abortion let's bring in patty
once again patty
how much of this is a reflection of the
changes that were going on in the
supreme court itself especially the new
appointments since the the trump era
this is a hundred percent happening
because this uh
because the donald trump was able to uh
put three justices on the court without
question it would not have happened
without that worth remembering barack
obama was in office and it was about a
year before the next election between
hillary clinton and donald trump and
mitch mcconnell the leader of the senate
in a very unusual step wouldn't even
give his supreme court nominee a hearing
he's now the attorney general merrick
garland and he said it's too soon to an
election to appoint a justice well then
uh justice scalia died and amy comey
barrett just about a month before the
next election and the republicans went
ahead and put that nomination through so
there's a lot of sore feelings among
democrats and independents in this
country about the way these supreme
court picks were handled not not to
mention the controversy about the
possible sexual assaults from brett
kavanaugh
the important thing i think to point out
is this is going to be a hugely
unpopular decision two-thirds of
americans in a recent poll said they
wanted roe v wade to stand they support
abortion access so the big question now
is what do they do next i have to say
just to paint the scene here i've been
here every single day that there's been
a decision day because we need to simply
wait to see if it's a decision that we
want to report on such as roe v wade
there's a lot more security here dhs the
department of homeland security has put
out a warning that they think extremists
are going to try and use this decision
to show violence they're
the pro-abortion rights and uh pro
and anti-abortion rights people
separated both with physical incident
with bicycle racks that's not happening
here so we expect throughout the day
we're going to see a lot more people
come to the supreme court and really
protests all over the country are
planned and expected
when the decision was leaked there was
an absolutely massive crowd of people
chanting against the decision so we
expect that we'll continue in the coming
days so the big question is what's next
can this court be overruled well yes the
court can be overruled if the congress
decides to pass a law protecting
abortion it can also be overruled if a
very very difficult procedure
it takes place it's very complicated
it's very costly but they can have a
constitutional amendment saying that
abortion is in fact
a woman's right to choose so those are
two possibilities but i expect to see
more in the near term as some of these
states that haven't explicitly said
abortion is illegal in their
constitution you're going to see
lawsuits challenging those individual
states so this is going to get very
messy the bigger concern for democrats
is the way this ruling was founded it
said well it's not rory wade basically
said under the right to privacy under
the 14th amendment
you have the right to an abortion
there's a lot of other court decisions
that took that same reasoning such as
same-sex marriage and the right to
interracial marriage
and so there's a lot of court decisions
now
that you can expect to see the most
conservative republicans try to push
because this is a supreme court that is
shown both with the gun decision
yesterday and roe v wade today that they
are willing to go against public opinion
and again
the vast majority of americans in this
country did not want this decision to
happen the supreme court made the
decision anyway
and this
patty no doubt guarantees that it will
be even more
of an issue in elections going forward
well it could be and i say that because
americans tend to vote with their
pocketbooks before anything else right
now americans are really mad at joe
biden they're really fed up with
congress gas prices are highest they
have ever been going to the grocery
store cost you more than it ever has
there's still shortages now joe biden
says that's because of the war in
ukraine he says it's because of the
pandemic and supply chain issues
americans might understand that but they
don't necessarily care about that
because their wages because of inflation
are not going as far as they used to so
a family that was just squeaking by is
now making really tough decisions about
buying gas buying food just the
essentials so americans are very angry
about that now americans a lot of
americans are going to be very angry
about this decision and democrats are
going to say look the only way to change
that is if you keep democrats in power
and you add on to our majority now there
this could potentially fire up the base
so that they are able to get more and
more people to vote if that issue breaks
through
but it's going to be interesting to see
because here you are you're competing
with the financial needs of your family
and a procedure that you care about but
maybe it's not you're not as passionate
about and that has been uh the thing in
this country republicans who are very
anti-abortion rights this is for many of
them their number one issue they voted
on it when it comes to state lawmakers
governors presidents senators
congressmen for democrats because it's
been a protected right for almost 50
years it really isn't one of the top
issues they'll tell you climate change
is way more important but now that that
was when you could get an abortion
anywhere in the country that is no
longer the case so it will probably have
some impact on the upcoming midterms and
obviously on the next presidential race
governorships are going to be more
interesting to see because these are
very red states
meaning republican leaning states that
have adopted some of the most
restrictive
laws and it's also not going to be
settled law because mississippi this law
says there are exemptions for
for
fetal abnormality or medical issues a
lot of these states are not allowing
that they're just simply saying no
abortions at all so is the court going
to have to come back and clarify exactly
what exemptions are allowed or not the
bottom line is this is going to throw
the whole issue of abortion into the
very topic of conversation because as of
today there are women right now who had
appointments in some of these states to
get an abortion today that will simply
not be able to do that so as i said in
my story they now have a
they have a decision to make do they
want to keep a child that they don't
believe they can afford or they don't
want do they want to try and find the
money which is expensive considering
most people don't have paid sick leave
or paid family leave they want to try
and find the money to go to a state that
allows it or as we saw before row there
were back room clinics there were very
dangerous perfor abortions performed do
they want to risk their own health in
order to get rid of this child so this
i know we say monumental decisions often
but really this is the very definition
of an
monumental change in this american
culture right you mentioned there the
popularity issue with joe biden when you
speak with both democrats and
republicans you get a sense of how they
feel this is going to play out shall we
say in the balance of power between the
two
[Music]
well they do but but they also
they also realize november's still a
little bit far further away people see
gas prices every day they won't
necessarily see
the impacts of abortions every day so
democrats are counting on this because
the polls were looking very bad for them
as far as
possibly losing the house
maybe losing the senate
so they're going to try and use this and
keep people fired up about this because
right now
people are very impassioned but
november's pretty far away
all right thanks so much patti calhane
reporting
from washington dc
we're continuing to look at those live
pictures reaction
coming in
to that decision taken by the u.s
supreme court which took that very
dramatic step of overturning the
landmark 1973 roe versus wade law